et en forêt libellules plantes
aquatiques
ils constituent une partie du patrimoine
de la ville de beaune elle sept communes
de moins de 2000 habitants est située au
coeur du parc de la haute vallée de
chevreuse la réserve naturelle a été
créée en 1990 au départ pour faire face
à la menace d'un projet de golf
elle a été élue capitale française de la
biodiversité en 2018 pour la
préservation de son patrimoine naturel
la ville a donc inauguré ce samedi 6
juillet la fête de la réserve
c'est une reconnaissance c'est pas un
aboutissement donc pour moi c'est
chouette parce que ça veut dire que tout
ce que l'on a fait n'a pas été n'est pas
entièrement idiot et donc on est reconnu
par des gens dont c'est la spécialité
qui est désunie vous avez fait des
choses bien mais après je rentre s'en
vante pas pour autant quoi mais très
sincèrement oui ça fait plus ça fait ça
peut choquer oui c'est sûr le parc
naturel de cheuvreux a mis en place une
journée de rencontres et de redécouverte
de la réserve et du parc
cette journée a été organisée dans le
cadre du plan paysager biodiversité des
versions de la rime donc c'est un
secteur sur lequel on est en train de
travailler actuellement pour en fait
créé un outil d'aidé à la décision
notamment pour les élus aujourd'hui
c'était l'idée de faire participer les
habitants à cette démarche là en les
faisant parcourir les paysages et en
leur demandant un peu leur perception
leurs idées sur ce qu'on pourrait faire
justement pour ce long et valoriser ses
paysages en déversant de l'arrimage des
conférences et visites guidées de la
réserve était au coeur de l'événement un
moment pour venir contempler
l'exposition de peinture sur des
paysages de la réserve c'est un lieu
reposant
apaisant et c'est vraiment un lieu où il
fait bon peindre une occasion pour les
associations comme l'amicale des
poissons de charte en est bonne elle
bullion nature d'échanger avec les
habitants un moment de convivialité en
famille ou entre amis grâce à une balade
organisée entre deux communes du conte
avait quarante participants qui faisait
donc une randonnée à pied de 9 km depuis
bonnet alla jusqu'à forge et en vélo des
forges jusqu à bonal pour revenir en
fait c'est un circuit que nous ne
connaissons pas tant de gens de forge
côte de beaune aide puisque c'est un
circuit qui ne peut être que pédestre on
peut pas le faire autrement que à pied
et est encore avec autorisation de
quelques propriétaires donc c'est vrai
que c'est du coup circuit très
inhabituel duquel on voit des paysages
super sympa quoi mais ça donne envie
d'essayer de le rendre possible par la
suite de manière ouverte pour tout le
monde quoi je pense que - toutes les
personnes qui ont participé à cette
cette balade ont bien compris qu'ils
avaient un intérêt très fort pour tout
le monde de connaître ce paysage pour
justement le respecter on a des prix
ouverte qui sont extraordinaires des
fonds de vallées des forêts vraiment
c'est sympa mais franchement certaines
personnes dix ans seront en vacances en
rando en pleine campagne à des
kilomètres des côtes de la région
parisienne
c'est vrai que ça fait plaisir parce que
nous sommes quand même argent et de
france le botaniste bernard chevassus au
louis président de l'association
humanité et biodiversité a animé un
débat suivi par la projection en plein
air du film la terre vue du coeur une
journée de fête qui se termine
tranquillement sur un transat
[Musique]